We're going to talk some more about
existentialism today
and I'm going to talk to you about a
couple of Swiss psychiatrists in swinger
and boss.
Just as a starting point.
Okay.
There are psychological viewpoint was
influenced to a large degree by a
philosopher named heidegger.
Yeah.
And heidegger considered himself a
student of being and for heidegger that
the main mystery of the world was why,
why it existed and the the best way to
think about the phenomenal,
he was a phenomenologist.
And the best way to think about
phenomenology and existentialism is that
phenomenology is the study of experience
as it's lived.
And then existentialism puts a twist on
that because existentialists assume that
being has implicitly moral dimension
and
the existentialists psychologists
presume that
pathology at least in part,
is a consequence of a disturbed
relationship,
a disturbed moral relationship with the
self and being.
It's very tricky thinking and it's not
often handled in personality courses
anymore,
but I think that's a big mistake.
The phenomenological element in
particular.
The one thing I really like about it is
that it's a really good counterpart to
modern materialistic viewpoint because
it puts consciousness at the center of
being,
instead of treating it as if it's
something that's a secondary phenomena
that emerges from something else.
And
okay,
our modern presuppositions,
especially the scientific
presuppositions or what passed for
scientific presuppositions,
are generally extremely reductionist and
they assume that consciousness is in
some manner that's not yet been
determined,
I guess secondary biproduct of
fundamentally material processes,
and it's a perfectly reasonable
hypothesis,
but I wouldn't say there's any real
evidence for it.
I mean,
it's,
it's hard to over state how mysterious
consciousness is as a phenomena.
Okay.
For heidegger,
consciousness was a mystery that was in
some sense equivalent to the mystery of
being and the way that the reason for
that was that he couldn't conceive of
existence without a soul,
without a subject.
So you can imagine if the world was
stripped of consciousness,
it's very difficult to describe what
would be left.
I mean,
if you take a very straightforward
materialistic viewpoint,
you could make the presumption that if
everything that was conscious was
eradicated,
then things would be just the way they
are now.
But
that,
I think that's a shallow viewpoint
because consciousness is what gives
everything a perspective,
gives it a size and it gives it a
duration and it gives it colors and all
the qualities that we associate with
being and without that consciousness,
all that,
at least in comprehensible.
And then there are deeper problems that
are dealt with by people like John
Wheeler,
who's a quantum physicist,
who believes that consciousness is
necessarily is necessary for quantum
indeterminacy to resolve itself into
something that's concrete in actual so
wheeler and many physicists like him put
consciousness at the center of the
process that turns potential into
actuality.
Now,
at the same time,
these quantum ideas were being
developed.
These philosophical ideas and
psychological ideas that I'm describing
are being developed and they provide
such a different take on the structure
of reality that
that I think they're indispensable.
I also think they're,
they're,
they're interesting in relationship in
particular to piaget's thought because
the phenomenologists have a
constructivist element to their thinking
in that
they believe that consciousness plays a
constructive role in the establishment
of being.
Okay,
so we're going to look at being,
so again,
the way to think about this is you've
got to flip your viewpoint in a sense is
you have to think about your experience
as reality and that everything that's
inside that experience,
so to speak as a subcomponent of that
reality instead of thinking of material
things as the reality and your
experience somehow emerging out of
those,
it's,
it's an inversion of what constitutes
the fundamental reality.
And so you could think about it in sense
as an intellectual exercise.
I mean most of the way that people think
is predicated on some kind of implicit
set of axioms.
And if you changed the axioms,
you can also,
you can often shed light on reality in a
new and interesting way.
And so we're going to walk through the
phenomenological viewpoint and we're
going to see
why and how that might be interesting,
the phenomenological and existential
viewpoints.
And then I'm in the next lecture.
I'm going to put a twist on that because
what you think about the nature of
reality appears to have some powerful
relationship with how that reality
unfolds itself and the existentialists,
the phenomenologists.
We're very big believers in the reality
of subjective experience and the
existentialists.
We're very big believers in the ethical
responsibility of the individual.
And I'm going to talk to you about what
happened in the Soviet Union between
1919 in 1959 which is a period of world
history that isn't well covered in our
culture.
I mean,
everybody knows about the Nazi
Holocaust,
but very few people know that between 30
million and 60 million people were
killed as a consequence of internal
repression in the Soviet Union between
1919 to 1959 that's a figure that is
five times as big as the commonly held
figures for the Holocaust.
And the reason I'm going to introduce
that to you is first you should know
about it because it's the stellar
example of what happens when people
abandoned their individual
responsibility.
And second and related to that,
it's an object lesson in why in what
happens when the presuppositions that
the phenomenologists and the
existentialists hailed about the nature
of reality,
we're completely dismissed in favor of a
rationalist,
utopianism and rationalist utopias
ideologically rational utopias killed
millions and millions of people in the
20th century.
And it seems to me that you can make a
fairly powerful case that
if,
uh,
if your view of reality when it's played
out in the social world turns genocidal
time and time again,
there's probably something existentially
wrong with it.
And then a secondary ovation of that
might be if there's something that
existentially wrong with a viewpoint in,
in what way can you consider it tenable
even if it makes sense.
And it's rational.
If the outcome is genocide and deceit
and misery,
it's perfectly reasonable to presume
that that's evidence that it's wrong.
Now,
most of you,
and this is particularly true,
I think of universities are taught a
kind of at least a kind of implicit
moral relativism.
You know,
that it's,
it is and that's fair.
That's reasonable from a scientific
perspective at least to some point.
But there's a problem with that because
there are forms of moral presupposition
that seemed to lead to horrendous ends
and it's always struck me because I grew
up like you and under the shadow of
nuclear destruction,
so to speak,
it always has struck me that if certain
viewpoints lead to
genocide load comes,
if they do that consistently,
then it's extremely dangerous for us not
to act as if that's wrong.
And of course if something's wrong,
then that also implies that something is
right,
right?
Because the opposite of wrong just
right.
And so even if you can't necessarily
figure out what's right,
you might be able to ground yourself to
some degree by figuring out what's
wrong.
And so we'll walk through the philosophy
and the psychology first and then we'll
walk through the sociological
consequences of it's abandonment in a
sense and well then you can see for
yourself if you think that this
perspective is worthy of some
consideration.
It's very complicated.
Okay,
well we'll look at this first.
Okay.
Phenomenology in part is based on this
idea of [inaudible] and [inaudible]
means being there.
And again,
this way of simplifying madness is to
think about it as your experience.
And then this is a map I've made of
people's experience,
which I think is at least roughly
equivalent to the phenomenologists
design.
And it has the advantage that I can
explain it well,
so I'm going to use it.
And so the phenomenologists believed
that the past and the present and the
future all tangled up together in your
current experience in that say
everything that you're doing is related
to the future,
which of course is because you're
sitting in this class that has some
consequences for whether or not you
graduate.
And that has some consequences for your
status and your career moving forward.
And you're perfectly aware of that so
that you experienced the meaning of the,
the lecture say in the context of your
conceptions of the future.
And of course the same thing is true of
your experience now because of your
past.
And so the past and the future in some
sense are here now.
It's partly because
when you're experiencing things,
okay,
you consider your current situation and
you consider
where it is that you're headed.
And so dad's side and also has this
element of becoming in it.
There's you're not just a static thing
and you don't ever experience anything
that's in your environment as something
that's merely static.
You always experiencing,
you're always experiencing it in
relationship to your plans for
transformation.
And that might be short term,
like maybe your board of the class
because you need to go get a cup of
coffee and not colors your current
experience or maybe it's long term or
medium term.
It doesn't matter.
The point is is that your viewpoint of
the future conditions,
your experience in the present.
So in some sense the future is already
here.
It's also the case that what you do now
is going to have effects and
consequences into the future.
Here's a,
here's the more complicated consequence.
So you're somewhere now and you're going
somewhere in the future and one of the
consequences of that is that your
nervous system,
it's one way of looking at it parses up
the world in relationship to the
relationship between those two poles.
So,
for example,
when you walk into a class and your plan
is to sit down,
then you're immediately going to
perceive an array of chairs.
Imagine you were coming in here to clean
up the room instead of sitting down for
a lecture.
Well then the things that would manifest
themselves to you would be qualitatively
different.
So maybe you'd only be looking for the
things that were out of place.
Or maybe you're coming in here because
you're a spectacularly lonesome and you
think that you know there's some buddy
here who might be a potential partner.
And then the world's going to array
itself in front of you in a different
manner.
And the degree to which what you're
pursuing in relationship to where you
are determines even how the objects of
the world manifest themselves to you is
indeterminate.
It happens to a tremendous degree.
And it's not only that things manifest
themselves to you as objects in
relationship to your conception of your
current situation and your goals,
but your emotions are also hang on that
platform.
So,
for example,
if you're writing an exam and you expect
to see you're hoping for a c and you get
a b,
then you're going to be extremely happy
about it.
But if you are hoping for an a and you
get a b,
then you're going to be extremely
unhappy about it.
And what's interesting about that is
that in some sense the stimulus as the
behaviors would have it is the same,
but the emotional consequences actually
reversed.
It seems to me to be sort of related to
the idea of Maya,
which is a Buddhist idea,
which is that people live inside a
framework that's conditioned by desire
and as a consequence it's not actually
real.
And the unreal lead,
the unreality of it is that you can
change what manifests itself to you and
the importance of what manifests itself
to you by changing your conception of
your,
of your goal,
your future,
or also by changing your conception of
who and where you are right now.
And so in that sense being your
experiences malleable and
it's,
it's malleable at least in part as a
consequences of the choices that you
make.
And so what that implies from a
phenomenological perspective is that
freewill and the manner in which the
world manifests itself are integrally
related and from an existential point of
view,
it implies that you actually bear a fair
bit of responsibility for the ongoing
quality of your experience.
And the existentialists would presume
that that responsibility is built into
the nature of being.
There's no way out of it.
It's like a precondition for being
they,
the word phenomenon is from a Greek word
and the Greek word is famous thigh and
what saint is thigh means is to shine
forth.
Now one of the presuppositions of the
phenomenal logical viewpoint is that
reality and in some sense is composed of
what shines forth.
Now this is a very difficult thing to
explain,
but I can do it partly this way.
So when you're moving from point a to
point b,
you can parse the world up into tools
and obstacles.
I showed you that in the last slide.
Tools or things that get you to where
you're going.
And so what the tools are,
it depends on where you're going and
obstacles are the things that get in
your way.
And so if you perceive tools,
then that makes you happy because
happiness,
at least in part,
is experienced in relationship to
movement towards a goal.
And if you experienced nothing but
obstacles that's going to produce
negative emotion.
And so this is a variant of that.
And the variant is when you're moving
from point a to point b,
you can experience things that you
predict or desire and those make you
hopeful and happy or you can experience
things that are unpredictable and those
make you,
those are threats and they make you
anxious,
but it's broader than that.
They disinhibit negative emotion in a
more general sense.
But sometimes you can experience
something that's so unpredicted and so
shocking that it blows the framework
that you're using it.
It,
it,
what would you say the phenomenologists
called?
That loss of world,
the framework,
the thing that you encounter is so
unexpected that it's appearance blows
the structure of being apart.
And that happens,
for example,
when people are betrayed by someone that
they love or maybe they're very
seriously hurt or they develop a very
serious illness or,
or a dream that they've been pursuing
for a long period of time,
he's rendered impossible by some failure
or,
or some unexpected natural occurrence.
Now,
part of the question is,
what do you,
when your world falls apart,
your world emerges from something and
then when it falls apart,
it falls back into that something that
chaotic state.
And that the phenomenologists say that
what you experience most basically is
meaning.
So for,
from a phenomenological perspective,
when,
when you're looking at the world you
perceive meaning and then you derive
objects from that and you just arrived,
the objects in relationship to your
representation of your current state and
your future state.
So from a phenomenological perspective,
the base of the world is meaning.
Now I can,
I can give you some hints about how that
plays itself out.
So,
so,
so one
interesting phenomena
is
how interest guides your ability to
concentrate.
Okay.
So let's say that you've got,
uh,
an array of difficult papers on your
desk.
And you have to read them.
Now.
Some of those papers independently of
their difficulty,
some of those papers will presume that
you're actually interested in and some
of them you're not interested in.
And so,
so the papers that you're interested in
come with this quality that the
phenomenologists described,
a shining forth.
There's something about them that grips
your attention,
that enables you to concentrate,
that enables you learn and that enables
you to remember and in a relatively
effort,
effortless way.
Whereas the other papers that you're not
interested in,
assuming there have equivalent
difficulty,
it's very difficult to focus your
attention on and they lie there in sort
of an inert manner.
So,
okay.
The fit thin,
his thigh phenomenon is partially
apprehendable by considering what the
differences to you between something
that you're interested in and something
that you're not now.
Yeah,
someone like you would think of that
interest as a consequence of an internal
process,
a psychological process that's guiding
your attention.
But the phenomenologists at least in,
it's tricky because they go both ways on
this would consider the fact that some
things are illuminated so that they're
easy to concentrate on is actually a
function of being itself.
It isn't something that you apply to the
world.
It's a characteristic of being.
Some things shine forth as meaningful
and some things don't.
Now the existentialists would say at
least in part that you have a duty to
follow the things that shine forth.
That's where the moral element of this
comes in.
Now,
Ben Swagger said,
for example,
what we perceive our first foremost not
impressions of tastes,
tone,
smell or touch.
Not even things or objects,
but meanings.
And then Ben Swagger and boss split on
the
reason for
why some things manifest themselves as
compelling and some things don't.
Bins Wanger would say that you come
equipped with an,
it's like it's a Kantian idea with an a
priori ontological structure and that's,
imagine you're reading a book.
Okay.
So then you might say,
and the book obviously has meaning
you're reading it and you're,
you're into it.
You might ask yourself,
where is the book?
Okay.
And you could say,
well,
the book is the physical object that I
have in my hand.
I mean that's,
that's what people act like in some
sense.
Or at least that's what they say.
They act like the book is the physical
object.
But then person a might read the book
and say,
I thought that was a terrible book.
And Person B might read that book and
say,
I thought that was a great book.
And Person A and B might differ on how
they responded to the characters.
And they're going to differ in terms of
how the imagine the situation.
And like there's a tremendous amount of
flexibility in exactly what constitutes
the book.
And so you'd say,
well,
the book is an artifact and the artifact
is produced by the the author.
But of course it's not just produced by
the author because it's produced inside
a cultural context that shape the author
and that shaped you.
And then you bring something to bear on
the book,
which is the sum total of your
individual knowledge and you're
enculturated knowledge.
And so what that means is that it's
almost as if there's a pattern that
constitutes you and there's a pattern
that constitutes the book and when you
put the two of them together,
you get a juxtaposition of the two
patterns and it's the juxtaposition
that's the book and it's,
it's the realization of it.
This in some part it's led to the
oddities of postmodernism and and to the
claim that there's no canonical meaning
to any given text because it's a matter
of interpretation.
It's like,
yeah,
well just because it's a matter of
interpretation and even maybe just
because the interpretations are very
wide in potential scope,
that doesn't mean that the text doesn't
have any meaning,
but you can understand how that idea
might've come about now for been
swinger.
The reason the book would be meaningful,
at least in part it's because you're
imposing something on it and so that
would be your individuality.
Boss would say the opposite.
He would say,
well,
no,
the book itself is manifesting its
meaning to you in some sense of its own
accord and that that's because
boss doesn't make a distinction
between the thing.
The book and the entire context within
which it's embedded.
And he would consider the meaning
emerging as a consequence of that entire
context.
You can't separate the book out from the
situation in which it's embedded.
Here's a map that I made a while back
that helped me understand this,
at least to some degree,
the phenomenologists talk about three
elements of being of Dad's side.
One is the unwell,
the other,
another is the Mitt wealth.
And the third is the AIGA dwells.
And there are various ways to
conceptualize these.
And I can give you a couple.
Now,
the Umwelt is the natural world.
So when we say nature,
that's what we mean.
We say,
well,
human beings live in nature.
We have a natural environment.
So the idea that there's a natural
environment is like a canonical idea.
And,
and you know,
we,
we even think of the natural environment
sometimes as the unspoiled natural
environment as if they're our natural
environments that exist in the complete
absence of human
endeavor.
And then we also have a social world.
And the social world is the world of
culture.
So there's nature and culture.
And that's Umwelt and Mitt wealth.
And then finally,
other than that,
there's the world of the self,
which is the part of being
your being that's only accessible to
you.
So it's you
in,
in the middle of culture,
in the middle of nature.
And so those are the elements of
Dad's side.
And
for
Ben Swagger,
it's the mid belt that contains most of
the meaning,
or at least that structures the meaning.
So if you're reading a great novel,
the degree to which you can extract
meaning from it is a consequence of your
previous education and your own
inculturation.
But
that isn't necessarily the only way.
Look at things like
if you walk into a bookstore,
say,
and a book catches your eye,
you might say that that book caught my
eye while you think,
what exactly does that mean?
Well,
it means that out of all the innumerable
entities in the bookstore that could
have caught your eye,
only that one did.
And then you might ask why.
Well,
in Boston would say,
well,
the world is disclosing a particular
meaning to you.
Why?
Well
that has something to do with the way
that you're playing out your individual
destiny.
Yeah.
Let's show you this first.
So this is both a constructivist Stan,
a phenomenological perspective.
And so here,
here's the idea that the thing that's at
the center of reality is the domain
that's not yet mapped.
So
you're in a relationship,
okay.
The relationship is betrayed before
you're betrayed,
you're in one place and after you're
betrayed,
you're in another place.
Before you're betrayed,
your world is all structured and you
know where you are and what you're doing
and who you're with and what everything
is.
The second after you're betrayed.
None of that's true.
And so
the second after your be trade,
nothing is structured.
It's like everything reverts to see to a
chaotic place.
And so in some sense,
the only time that you encounter a pure
view of what the world itself is made
out of,
what the ground of being is,
is when you encounter an error that's so
overwhelming that your current framework
of meaning is no longer applicable.
So the framework blows apart.
But it isn't as if nothing happens when
the framework blows apart.
Like if you're in a committed
relationship and you find security in
that and you believe that the security
is genuine and that's blows apart,
then everything that you presumed is
wrong,
that's your mid dwelt.
But when that disappears,
there's something underneath it.
And what's underneath it?
That's the,
that's the ground of reality.
And the ground of reality is what you
explore to put yourself back together
and to put the world back together.
So you're betrayed and you fall into a
depression and you're anxious.
But you know,
there's always the possibility of a new
relationship that beckons.
And perhaps your previous relationship
wasn't perfect.
So the chaos that you fall into is
depressing and anxiety provoking.
So generates a lot of negative emotion,
but sort of lurking behind that are the
sort of dim remnants of hope.
And then as you proceed forward with
your grief and your misery,
and you're attempting to reconstruct a
stable motive being you take out of that
thing,
that's a normal us,
you and the world.
So another way of thinking about this is
that for the phenomenologists,
and this is where they're similar to the
constructivists,
the ground of reality isn't so much
matter as it is information and when
you're,
when you're living in in your
constructed world and things are going
the way that you want them to go,
then you've constrained that information
in a particular way,
constrained and narrowed it in a
particular way that serves your
particular narrow end and that that
makes things much more comfortable
because then you don't have to deal with
the,
the information that constitutes the
entire world.
You can remove most of it and say,
well all that's relevant to me,
all that necessarily makes up my world
of being are these
circumscribed is this circumscribed set
of phenomena and that works well when
it's working,
but when it doesn't work and it blows
apart,
that puts you somewhere else and that
that being put somewhere else can be
well revelatory sometimes.
I mean sometimes people make new
discoveries that blow their previous
frames of reference and it's like are
inspiring and overwhelming to them in a
positive way.
Sometimes you can come across something
new that helps you reconfigure the way
that you're living almost instantly in a
more comprehensive and fuller way.
But more common is the traumatic
response,
which is when the presuppositions of
your world are shifted dramatically and
you fall into the surrounding chaos,
then it's so hard on you that you know
it actually does use psychophysiological
damage.
No.
You remember that
drawing I showed you
with the little ovals at the bottom and
the bigger ovals at the top,
the hierarchy,
you remember that?
Does everybody remember that
I decomposed say good person,
which is a very high order abstraction
down to put a fork on the table,
which is a motor movement that's part of
making dinner,
which is part of being a good parent,
which is part of being a good citizen,
which is part of being a good person.
So the idea was that the higher order
abstractions can be concretized down to
the motor behaviors in hierarchy.
Okay.
Now.
Yeah,
if someone goes after you at the good
person level of analysis and they just
demolish you,
you know in the course of say a three
year relationship hacking away at the
idea that you have any moral worth
whatsoever,
this is what happens when you're abused,
then that's going to knock you into
pieces at a very complex and high level
of abstraction.
So that can undermine your entire
worldview if the person instead,
yeah,
helps you retool the little behaviors
and little micro structures that make
you up and if you're willing to
participate in that and if you're open
to corrective feedback from the world,
then you can continually adjust yourself
at a small level and then that makes the
things in the hierarchy little higher,
a little healthier,
and then that makes the aggregation of
those things a little higher in the
hierarchy,
a little healthier and little more
complete.
Then you can do this
bit by bit retooling
without ever having to suffer the
demolition of huge chunks of your
personality.
So let's go back to the relationship
where there's a betrayal.
It's like virtually every time someone
gets flipped upside down because of a
betrayal interrelationship after the
betrayal happens,
they say to themselves,
there were all these signs I didn't pay
attention to.
So when maybe the first sign is who
knows,
your partner starts to flirt a bit more
when you go out on a social occasion and
not a lot more,
just a bit more and you decide because
maybe you're timid that that that's
okay,
you're not going to just do anything
about it but,
but it's,
it's interesting that it happens.
It grabs your attention and it means
something.
But what you decide is it's not worth
paying attention to.
And so maybe the next eight times that
you go out,
the same thing happens,
but it happens at a somewhat accelerated
rate and then maybe the person starts to
go out without you and so on.
There's this progression towards the end
state of betrayal and every time you get
a little hint,
the world tells you that something's
going on,
you put it aside and you failed to take
it into account.
Well
you're forgoing your opportunity.
Yeah,
to adjust the relationship.
At micro stages because maybe what you
should've done the first time that
happened is you should have gone home
with your partner and sad,
um,
what the hell is going on?
Like this is what was happening,
why are you doing that?
Um,
here's how you should have behaved.
And of course that's going to be a
fight.
There's absolutely no doubt about it,
but
it might be a micro fight instead of a,
the relationship is over fight and in
order to keep our relationship healthy,
it needs,
yeah,
it'd be retooled at micro levels
constantly and the same as the case with
your own character.
When you encounter something that's
unexpected,
especially if it's small enough to
handle,
you need to extract the information from
it,
rebuild the world and rebuild yourself.
And then maybe if you continue doing
that,
every time you get evidence of an
anomaly or an error or every the world
manifest some meaning to you,
then you won't have to fall apart
because the structure that constitutes
you is going to remain viable and
healthy from the bottom up.
And if you don't do that,
then those errors are going to
accumulate.
And when they finally do manifest
themselves as unavoidable,
like when your partner says,
I don't want to be with you anymore,
or I've been with someone else for the
last year,
there's no ignoring that,
then the whole thing comes crashing
down.
You're no longer in a relationship,
you're no longer in a good relationship.
And then all the other things become
questionable.
So
meaning manifests itself
so that you can read tool
being itself.
Yeah,
on a continual basis.
Well simultaneously minimizing the risk
of total collapse and morality then
becomes the act of paying sufficient
attention and reacting sufficiently so
that that corrective process occurs now.
So you're inside one of these,
you're going from point a to point b.
And as you do that,
things you want to have happen,
happen and things you don't want to have
happen and things you don't understand
happen.
And let's say that you investigate
the things that you don't want to have
happen and you investigate the things
that you didn't expect and you do that
as soon as they come up.
So then what happens?
Well,
partly what happens is you're going to
change your perceptions a bit and you're
going to change your actions a bit.
And what that'll,
okay
culminating over time is that this whole
structural change.
So instead of going from point a to
point b,
maybe you start shifting so that you're
going from point a to point c because as
you're gathering information,
as a consequence of the inadequacies of
the way you're looking at the world,
not only are you improving your ability
to perceive and to act,
but you're also gathering information
that helps shift your perspective to a
better point b.
Because you might say,
well,
where are you going and why?
And the answer to that is while you have
a plan,
you're going to get your degree.
I don't know what your longterm plan is,
but there's no reason to assume that
your longterm plan is correct even
though there's no reason to assume that
you can do without one.
So you're in this weird situation where
you have to live within a bounded space
and the bounded space is going to
produce errors and it's also going to be
wrong.
But at the same,
if you use the bounded space,
then you can transform it continually
across time,
even what it's aimed at and you can
minimize the probability of precipitous
collapse.
Now
I want to show you how this has been
represented.
It's very complicated and difficult.
Okay?
So on the right you see that the Harry
Potter snitch thing,
right?
And then on the left here you see this
incredibly peculiar l chemical
image.
And the image is something like this.
This is what this image means.
It means at the base of the world is
this weird combination of matter and
spirit.
So this is matter and this is spirit.
The winged element represents spirit.
And then out of that comes something
that's like primordial and Reptilian.
that's associated with consciousness.
So it's,
it's like,
uh,
it's a map of the way that consciousness
emerges from the base of reality.
Now
you'll see that this thing and that
thing,
the snitch and that this thing is called
a round chaos.
This thing,
the snatch and the round chaos are the
same thing.
Now in in Harry Potter,
when he plays Quidditch,
remember piaget had such an emphasis on
games,
right?
Piaget believed that games were the sub
elements of human culture.
And quidditch is this weird two level
game.
We're on one level,
it's sort of like soccer,
basketball,
and then on another level you have two
players that are seekers.
And what they seek is this snitch
and the snatch is this thing that
captures your attention.
That's why it's Goldman winging.
It moves around very fast.
It's like mercury,
the spirit mercury,
because mercury,
the God had winged feet and he was the
messenger of the gods.
So that's,
that's how mercury was conceived of it.
I'll tell you something else that's
weird about mercury.
So mercury is a metal as well.
And if you mix mercury with sand and the
sand has gold in it,
then the mercury will pick up the sound
and then or the gold,
and then you can heat up the mercury.
And all that's left is gold.
So Mercury will lead you to where the
gold is and the spirit Mercurius the
mercurial spirit was the messenger of
the gods.
And if you paid attention to mercury,
the God,
then you gathered the gold.
But it wasn't the gold of fools.
It was the gold that made your lives
valuable.
And that's the same thing that's played
out in this weird quidditch game.
The two best players,
the fastest,
the ones that are most awake aren't
playing the normal game.
They're playing a super ordinate game
and the super ordered game is pay
attention,
pay attention.
And if you pay attention then you'll get
the thing
that's most valuable.
You win the game.
But there's more than that because in
the Harry Potter series,
for example,
there was a piece of soul in that.
And that's related to the idea that if
you pay attention to what interests you,
what manifest itself is meaning full.
Not only do you build the world out of
that because you're differentiating
something that's undifferentiated into
something that's comprehensible and
usable,
but at the same time you're doing the
same thing to yourself.
Cause.
And that's the constructivist idea,
right?
It's that,
well,
where do you,
where do you come from?
Well,
you come from exploration and the
generation of information and
exploration.
What should you explore while the things
that shine forth to you?
That's the phenomenal logical idea and
existential idea is if you refuse to
explore the things that shine forth for
you,
that capture your interest in your
attention,
then that will lessen you as a big,
it'll make you weaker and progressively
weaker because not only do you remain
unformed,
but the ratio of chaos to world in your
domain of being becomes too intolerable,
too much chaos,
not enough order,
not enough of you.
Then the whole thing is unstable.
Then you've only got two options.
One is that you lose belief than being
itself and that's like a nihilistic
reaction.
And the other is you turn to some sort
of totalitarian or ideological solution
that fills in for where you're not,
and that's an abdication of your
individual responsibility.
And the consequences of turning to
totalitarian ideologies like that is
that
they stagnate and become brittle because
there's no transformation in them
anymore.
Because all of the people inside of them
have decided that transformation is
unnecessary.
And so they become increasingly outdated
and corrupt.
And then
okay,
that's the first step on the way to
having everything fall apart in the most
horrible possible way.
And that plays out at the state level,
just like it plays out at the individual
level.
I'll tell you a dream I had about this
since we're just out of the
psychoanalytic domain,
I can show you using this,
how dreams often
solve problems.
Okay,
I'll just read it to you cause I wrote
it when I just,
after I had it all,
I'll just tell it to you.
So
the first thing I saw was
it was like a view from a space shuttle.
So it was a global view and I could see
the Atlantic Ocean and on the surface of
the Atlanta Goshen,
there were four hurricanes and they were
in a quadrant like this.
So there was a circle here in a circle
here in a circle here in a circle here.
And then we're very large hurricanes.
I mean one hurricanes quite good.
But for,
that's a lot of hurricanes.
So it was impressive.
And so then the next thing I saw was a
bank of scientists in kind of a dark
room watching TV screens focused on this
hurricane storm event and wondering what
was going on.
And then the next thing I saw was this
little ball about this big hovering over
the surface of the ocean.
So now I was in the eye.
So the four hurricanes had an eye in the
middle of the immuno,
a calm place.
And so this little ball,
which was about 10 feet above the
surface of the water,
was in that calm place.
And the storms were,
it's a company mint.
So,
and it was zooming along at a very rapid
rate and it was bringing the storms with
them.
And so all of the scientists with their
satellites,
we're trying to figure out what this
little ball that was 10 feet off the
ocean surface and the needed like four
hurricanes to accompany in that a
company yet they're trying to figure out
what this thing was.
Okay.
So the next scene was I was a third
person observer and I was in this room.
It was a small room,
about eight by eight,
say in the middle of the room there was
this display case like a museum,
you know,
like a Victorian Museum.
So it was made out of wood,
the top,
it had this glass and inside the case
was this ball and it was just floating.
And inside the room was Steven Hawking,
you know,
the physicist in the wheelchair and a
faceless president of the United States.
It didn't matter who he was,
it just mattered that he was president
of the United States.
And then the room itself,
I remember from the dream was made out
of titanium dioxide.
And I woke up and I after this dream and
I thought,
what the hell is titanium dioxide?
And the walls were seven feet thick.
So that the idea was that little ball
which had caused those four storms was
going to be,
they caught it and they put it in that
room and it was going to stay there.
Titanium dioxide turned out to be the
metal that the hall of the starship
enterprise is built out of.
Yeah.
So it's,
it,
it represented like an impermeable
substance.
And so the,
so there was this box made out of this
high tech metal and then inside the room
the American president was there.
So he sort of representative of the myth
dwelt,
you know,
the social environment.
He sort of King of the social
environment.
And then Stephen Hawking,
while Stephen Hawking is disembodied
rationality,
right?
Obviously.
So,
so the room was a classification system
in a sense.
And this ball,
whatever it was,
was stuck in there.
And so it was going to be a thing that
you could look at in a museum and it
wasn't going anywhere.
So it had been fixed.
And so I was watching this thing
and then
when I was watching it,
it did two weird things in the museum
case,
the first thing it did was turned into a
Chrysalis.
And then you know what a Chrysalis is.
It's like a cocoon that a butterfly
comes out of.
And you may not know this,
but the word,
the Greek word for butterflies,
psyche,
and the reason the psyche is a butterfly
is because the psyche is something that
transforms and it transforms towards
something.
Let's like an aerial spirit.
So this ball was transforming.
It transformed into a Chrysalis and then
it did a really strange thing.
It transformed into a pipe like a
smoking pipe.
It was a mere Sharm pipe,
which is a carve pipe,
I think it's Irish sort of looks like a
little saxophone and thing,
but it was definitely a pipe.
And so that was the whole dream.
And I woke up and I thought I got the
Chrysalis idea,
this whatever this ball was,
was the thing that's capable of
transforming.
But then I thought,
what the hell,
what does that mean?
What could that possum pipe possibly
mean?
Yeah,
one other thing transformed into
Chrysalis and then back to a ball and
then it transformed into a pipe and then
back into a ball and then went and shot
out of the case and shot right through
the seven feet walls and it was gone and
it just left a hole.
Like there was,
it was moving so fast,
there was just a hole in the case and
there was a hole in the wall.
And that was the end of that.
So it,
it was a ball.
It did its Chrysalis thing,
get his pipe thing,
and then it was gone.
That barks was not going to hold it.
So after I had that dream quite a while
later,
two years later,
I read this little poem from Dante is
from the inferno.
The inferno is an interesting book
because it's Dante is attempt.
It's a,
it's a book about hell and it's Dante is
attempt in a sense to turn the old idea
of hell into something that was
psychological.
So Dante has this vision of hell as this
place has multiple depths with something
that's the absolute worst right at the
center.
So in some sense it's his attempt to
come up with a category structure of,
of evil.
He actually puts betrayers right in the
center.
He figured that was the worst form of,
of moral error.
Anyways,
here's part of the poem.
Virgil and Dante are going into the
inferno.
Virgil's the guide.
Suddenly they're broke on the dirty
swell of the dark marsh,
a squall of terrible sound that sent a
tremor through both shores of hell.
A sound as if two continents of air,
one frigid in one scorching clashed head
on in a war of wins that strips the
forest bare,
ripped off whole boughs and blew them
helter skelter along the range of dust
it raised before it making the beasts
and shepherds run from shelter run for
shelter.
That's a messenger from God comes down
and that's how he makes himself
manifested.
Right.
Wow.
That's very much like this dream.
I had two continents of air
and
there was this similar idea that there
was something at the center that was
there.
Couldn't be encapsulated in a,
okay,
what a conceptual structure.
At least not for any length of time.
And you know,
being is like that.
You can't encapsulate it in a conceptual
structure for any length of time,
no matter what you think you're wrong.
And even if you're right enough for the
time being,
being is transforming and you have to
keep up with it because otherwise the
structure that you were inhabiting
becomes dead and decays and then you
fall apart.
And so you need a conceptual structure
because it orients you,
but it can't be static.
And that's the problem with totalitarian
ideology is that totalitarian ideology
is predicated on the idea.
It's utopia that you can finally model
things once and for all.
And so once you do that,
it's perfect and then it never has to
change.
And that's,
that's wrong.
Technically,
it's not wrong arbitrarily.
It's not a kind of a relative wrong,
it's just wrong.
And it's because whatever being is,
it's not static.
And so whatever it is that you inhabit
to allow being to work in your favor
also can't be static,
even though it has to be a structure.
Then I figured out why it was a pipe and
not talk about three years for me to
figure that out.
And this is a famous painting by
Magritte,
right?
And so it says this is not a pipe.
So what does that mean?
What does he mean?
The first question is,
is it a pipe?
What did we think?
Kind of idea.
But that's
the image.
It's certainly,
it's actually an image of an image of a
pipe,
right?
Because we're projecting it.
But yes,
you're exactly right.
It's not a pipe.
And so what?
What's my greed trying to
communicate?
What's the idea?
The idea is the conception is not the
object or another way of putting it is
the map is not the territory and you
live in the map in some sense,
but the territory is always underneath
it and the reason that little ball
turned into a pipe was to make that
case.
It's like it was in this box and it was
being transformed into a,
an entity that was defined and static
and it it,
it said two things.
It said,
everything transforms.
That's the Chrysalis and everything
transforms into psyche because the
butterfly is psyche and then it said
don't mistake the map for the territory
and then it left and
the being that manifests itself,
the being that shines forth in the
phenomenologists sense is the thing that
cannot be encapsulated inside any
conceptual structure.
It's always outside of it.
It's always outside of it and you have
to keep up with it.
Well,
that's why in the Harry Potter book for
example,
the best players don't play that game.
They chased the snitch and what that
means is that they follow what manifests
itself to them as most meaningful at any
given time.
Now young would have thought of that as
the manifestation of the self cause he
would say,
and it's like I can never remember who.
I can never differentiate these two
thinkers
young's like bins wanger he assumes that
the meaning is a consequence of the
action of some internal structure,
more or less that he characterized as
the self
boss's perspective is more in some sense
it's more like a classical religious
perspective,
although he dispenses almost entirely
with any religion,
just language.
It makes the claim that meaning is the
fundamental fundamental element of being
and that if you lose touch with meaning,
then the quality of your being is going
to
collapse and not only yours but also the
meaning of the society that you're part
of it.
Because not only when you're,
when you're paying attention to what's
meaningful,
not only are you updating yourself,
are not,
not only are you improving the quality
of your own being,
but because you're embedded in this myth
welk and you're like a node in a
network,
your transformations effect the
transformations of the people around
you.
And so you can't only transform yourself
or fail to,
if you transform yourself,
you also transform society.
And if you fail to transform yourself,
then you also fail to transform society.
And if you fail to transform society,
then it stays static and it stays
static,
then it dies.
And so that's the relationship between
the phenomenal logical viewpoint and the
existential viewpoint.
To me,
what the phenomenologists force you to
grapple with is the phenomena of
meaning.
Because it seems to me,
and this is basically heidegger's point,
he said,
well,
what's self evident?
Well,
one answer is objects.
Okay?
The other ass answer is,
is is predicated on a different
perspective.
Yeah.
Meaning is self evident in that you
can't escape from it.
You can,
you can escape from the positive
elements of it by being locks.
But you cannot escape from the negative
elements of it.
You can't argue yourself out of it.
And,
and,
and you act as if there's nothing more
real.
So if you see,
if you think about it this way,
if is terrified,
they're going to act it out and you
cannot calm them down.
Using rational means if someone's in
pain,
it's the same thing.
Both anxiety or terror and pain are
forms of meaning and they're not.
They're underneath rationality in a
sense in the rationality is powerless
against terror and pain.
And if you're terrified,
then you'll act that way.
And if you're in pain,
And you might do everything you can to
say there's no such thing as meaning.
But if you're,
yeah,
b,
if your state of being is one of terror,
no matter what you say,
you're going to act like that's real.
And then you have to ask yourself
another question is,
okay,
what's more reflective of real,
what you say
or how you act
and it matters because what constitutes
real changes with weather?
Like what,
what defines real changes?
Or depending on how you answered that
question
and the existentialists
would say,
well,
how you act as what's Real,
how you act reflects what's real.
But greed played with this a lot.
So there's another painting by me.
Greet
you often uses men in suits.
Like a suit is representative of a
certain kind of a certain motive being,
and it's a mode of being that is focused
on,
it's focused rather narrowly on whatever
a business suit represents.
Dominance,
hierarchy,
key success,
um,
materialistic possessions.
That's the,
at least the cliched and satirical
version of business.
It certainly represents conformity.
And Magritte migrates painting is a
representation of blindness induced by
conformity.
These people can see,
but they're only seeing what's right in
front of their eyes and what's right in
front of their eyes that they see blocks
them from seeing everything else.
Yes.
In there in the first quarter of the
20th century.
More like kind of average.
Sure.
It's not a,
it's a,
it's,
it's conformity essentially.
Yeah.
And it's not only that,
it's,
it's like it's moral conformity,
you know?
I'm not saying that it's right,
it's,
it's that it,
it's in the guise of moral conformity.
If you wear a suit,
you're,
you're representing what the culture
perceives to be
associated with citizenship and
responsibility.
Lot of what [inaudible] did was to try
to dissociate
the structure from the underlying
reality.
And he does that.
For example,
in the painting on the right where
he takes any image and then juxtaposes
it with the wrong signifier.
Okay.
I suppose though in some sense those are
almost like that that painting is almost
like a poem in that the juxtaposition of
the label and the entity forces you to
imagine more than either of them would
force you to do alone.
Cause you might say,
well in what manner is a horse like a
door
and what and what manner is the clock
like the wind
or a picture like a bird?
Well and he returns to normal in the
last one and time flies like the wind.
When a horse is something that takes you
places,
it's like a door,
a bird.
It isn't exactly clear to me how vases
like the bird,
this is another dream
that's attempting to lay out the same
idea.
So you are what you know,
I believe it's Davinci,
the Da Vinci's Vitruvian man,
it's this figure.
Presume you've all seen it.
It's very,
very famous image.
So it's the man is in a square and then
the squares in a circle.
Yeah.
Um,
in this dream,
this dream had that image except the
square wasn't a square,
it was a cube.
So the figure inside the,
there was a figure inside the cube,
which was uh,
a man,
sort of a generic man or an idealized
man.
And the cube was about nine feet maybe
or eight feet by eight feet by eight
feet.
And the man was suspended in the middle
of the cube.
So he was about a foot and a half off
the floor floating.
And then
from his hands to the wall was about a
foot and a half and
he could reach close to the wall that
was in front of them.
And then the inside of the cube,
no matter where the man looked,
was covered with these squares,
with the circle in them.
And inside the circle there was a little
dragon's tail.
And if the man walked forward,
then the cube went with them.
And if the man walked backwards,
the cube went with them.
And so it was a representation of what
surrounds you in reality.
And then the man could reach out to any
of these squares with the circle,
with the tail,
and he can pull on one of the tails and
that would pull something into being.
And there were all these choices in
front of him that represented different
paths of being.
So.
So what that dream represented was this,
you know,
you might say,
well,
what is it?
It's right in front of you.
And then you could say,
well,
chairs and the floor and students and
light.
And
that's true.
But there's another way of thinking
about it,
which is that what's right in front of
you is a landscape of possibility to
which your conception of objects blind
you.
So
no matter where you're going in your
life,
the things that present themselves to
you,
okay.
Offer an array of almost unlimited
possibility.
And so when I look ahead and I see a
student or students,
then that makes all of you one bit of
information in a sense,
right?
Because I've generalized across all of
you and there's some utility in that,
in that
part of
what you're doing here can be
conceptualized as being a student.
But the loss in that perception might be
far greater than the gain because it
reduces all of your complexity to a
single utterance and makes you flat.
And so then you think as you wander
around the world,
are you seeing
this
or are you seeing a wall in front of you
that from which you can pull anything
you want,
that the standard viewpoint would be
that this is real.
But it seems to me that you can make a
reasonable case that what you interact
with is not so much reality as it is
possibility.
And so the possibility is what lurks
behind your conception of what's there.
And that possibility is also the thing
out of which everything emerges.
So if I,
if you come to my office and I sit and
talk to you and I
try to approach you without any
preconceptions which would be saying a
Rogerian approach,
then all sorts of things can emerge into
reality.
That wouldn't emerge at all if I stayed
rigidly in a prescribed role.
Now there's some utility in the
prescribed role,
don't get me wrong because it gives
people structure and it and it,
it helps to manage their expectations
and it protects them from being exposed
to too much possibility at any one time
because that can be overwhelming.
But the danger is,
at least in part that you'll blind
yourself to all the things that are
there by only allowing yourself to see
what you can immediately see.
The Buddhists talk about desire as
something to
push aside,
and I think that's
okay.
There.
Attempt to warn people about the danger
of substituting their own preconceptions
about what should be or what is
four,
four attention to what's behind that.
So imagine that you're depressed and
your board and all the positive meaning
has gone out of your life.
Well perhaps it's because you've
substituted your a Priori perceptions
for possibility and you're in this cage
that that's in part a mirror and all it
does is reflect back to you your sterile
preconceptions.
Well behind that is the possibility and
it's conceivable in that possibility,
which is maybe infinite possibility that
what it is that you lack now that's
making you so rigid and board could be
pulled out of that possibility.
Boss said man's option to respond to
this claim or to choose not to,
not to do so seems to be the very core
of human freedom.
All right,
so I'm going to return to a theme that I
developed partway through this lecture.
Yeah.
If being doesn't manifest itself to you
as structured,
then it's as if you're falling
endlessly.
It needs structure
is like a set of tools that that you
have at your disposal.
Now
the problem with structures that it can
blind you to possibility
and the possibility might be more
important than the structure.
And that means that partly what you have
to do is balance the possibility and the
structure.
One possibility is that the things that
manifest themselves to you as meaningful
are constituted gateway between
structure and possibility so that if you
follow that which shines forth,
then you stay sufficiently within the
structure.
But at the same time you're pulling in
enough new possibility so that the stays
dynamic and alive instead of static and
dead.
If if your nervous system,
Huh,
if you pay attention to the cues that
being is offering you,
showing you where to look and you are
actually look,
then maybe you can stay flexible enough
so that as things shift around you,
you don't
grow a huge gap between yourself and the
world and fall.
Maybe you just
interact,
you know,
like in a dance that's,
that's acceptable
emotional significance.
It's,
it's anxiety provoking enough to keep
you awake and it's compelling enough to
keep you interested.
And so those two things in some sense
constitute the core of meaning.
Okay.
In order to interact with the world in
that way,
you have to flip your preconceptions
upside down
and make the presupposition that the
material elements that people,
modern people regard as most real are
actually secondary and limited
derivations of something that's more
fundamental.
And the thing that's more fundamental is
possibility and possibility shines
through structure with meaning.
That's the phenomenal logical
perspective and the existential
perspective is follow that meaning or
suffer the consequences.
That's that.
See you Thursday.